Hey man, I'm Kevin Smith.
And today I'm going to be answering the internet question.
Um.
Would you rather do the first 90% of a blow job with a last time?
Hello?
Would you rather be stuck in Jumanji or Jurassic park?
No. This is a fantastic question.
Ain't you Mangi cause there's magic involved there, right?
Like that's how he got into the box or the video game,
depending on which version of Jumanji you're into. So if magic is involved,
that. Because then I could wind up with like eight or something. Um,
I'm going to pick drastic part.
Cause then it's all about it's that you just have to not get eaten.
It's not like suddenly a Raptor is going to be like,
forget a kiss and like magically do some to you.
Like they might in Jumanji and whatnot. So I'm going to go,
I've seen enough Jurassic parks where I think I know what to do, man. And, uh,
and yeah, plus the selfie clickbait alone,
just like stegosaurus, you know,
nobody's got that on their Instagram feed kids. Uh, next step.
Would you rather have a good hand job from your grandmother or a bad hand
job also from your grandmother? It gets no better.
I thought perhaps it'd be like, you know, good one from your grandmother,
bad one from your grandfather or vice versa.
And then it's a real like shark or a drowning situation. Um, well,
I mean, look, I'd always rather get a good hand job at the end of the day.
If you're going to be Dick out, something should come of it.
She's long passed and uh, pretty much on her memory. But yeah,
I'd like a good hand-job from my grandmother.
Would you take $4 million to be on to catch a predator?
Not to clarify you don't get, you don't get arrested. You just are on it.
You're on it. But it's like, Hey, you were wrong. I'm not actually,
but everyone watches you and sees you.
I was assuming I was getting 4 million to be the host.
And I was instantly going to say why. Yes, but Nope. Nope.
You're you're starring in it. The receiving end of it. I'm a, Hey,
what's going on here? That guy. And they ultimately prove that I'm okay.
But after the fact let's say on that show, it doesn't look good for you. I mean,
here's the thing like most people of course would be like, yeah man,
I'll look like a better for 4 million bucks. Um, I,
you know, I'm 48. So I stopped thinking like that in my twenties.
So I say to myself, 4 million bucks, you know,
you put your nose to the grindstone,
make about 1% of that without having to be on to catch a
predator.
Would you rather walk with a roller blade on your left shoe for the rest of your
life?
Or have a midget wait left shoe or have a midget walking in front of you walking
slightly slower than you want to for the rest of your life. And uh,
to add to it, the midget reportedly as a bad temper,
I'm going to go with the rollerblade now,
like to with people like I'm a real played solid Bob for a reason.
I don't want nothing. Don't start none. Won't be none.
So if I've got this shorter individual in front of me and like the whole time
I'm like, come the. Like I know sooner or later I'd be like, did you come on?
So rather than have that moment, just skip it all together,
put it on the skate.
Would you rather do the first 90% of a blow job with a last 10%?
This is almost as good as the Jurassic park question. Oh my God, this is good.
Let me think about this before I give you an answer off the top of my head.
Most of the other ones, I was just blowing through,
like trying to just be clever, but this requires a serious thought.
The last 10%, of course, big climax. And that is,
I think the only thing that has kept me from being gay my whole life,
my brother is gay. His days long has been married to a man for 25 years.
The only reason I never became a full-blown homosexual is because I don't know
that I would know what to say to somebody after they came in my mouth like that,
nobody taught me like what the conversation is like, what does one sale a Crow?
And do you wait and do you just say in seven,
I've asked my brother many times and he's like, Kevin,
that's not the only reason you're not gay. Nobody would you.
So I think I'm not,
I'm not like I'm not against fluids and stuff like that.
So I'm not gonna say that on don't want to do the last 10% because like cheese,
cheese,
but I am a hard worker and methodical and I have,
I know what a man wants. So I think I'd pick the 90% man.
You don't get a lot of the credit. You know, the 10% gets all the credit and.
But like, to me, that makes all the difference.
I'd be like the bull Durham of blow jobs.
I don't know if you're familiar with that movie, but Tim Robbins was the star.
He's the 10%, there was a guy who trained him, men,
the player to be named later. That's who I feel I am and stuff. That's the 90%.
I'm the bull Durham. 90%. I don't need you to know about my record.
I can quietly go break it off camera someplace.
Thank you so much.